[Musica]
a proposito di orizzonti
l'etica amplia i suoi orizzonti sta
ampliando i suoi orizzonti che cosa
significa questo significa che il
l'ambito entro cui noi possiamo
interrogarci su ciò che è bene per noi o
su ciò che è giusto o sbagliato nel
nostro agire nel mondo si sta ampliando
si sta ampliando anche possiamo dire
fisicamente cioè nello spazio e nel
tempo e come vedremo appunto in questo
breve discorsetto
e questo ci consentirà di vedere anche
il nostro mondo in un modo diverso da
una prospettiva diversa ma per parlare
di questo
vediamo da dove siamo partiti
partiti cioè quale l'etica da cui
partiamo al che si dovrebbe ampliare
l'etica tradizionale
considerare il rapporto con gli altri
esseri viventi come moralmente neutro
cioè la natura era la base della nostra
vita non era un oggetto di riflessione
morale normalmente noi anche oggi forse
non proprio sempre pensiamo che la
natura sia un oggetto di riflessione
morale sicuramente
questo non era in passato
inoltre elettrica tradizionale
antropocentrica cioè al suo al suo
centro l'uomo e assegna valore positivo
solo all'azione dell'uomo nei confronti
dei suoi simili questo anche per esempio
l'etica ed angelica no la morale
evangelica cioè i ris il rapporto con il
prossimo è la cosa importante lì nascono
i valori li si decide che cosa è buono
che cosa non lo è
oggi si dice qualcuno osserva forse non
c'è solo questo forse c'è una sorta di
mutuo appello che sarà dalla natura e
che ci dice che
forse ci sono altri valori che noi
dobbiamo tenere presenti nella
riflessione etica oggi ed è per questo
che ci possiamo chiedere se ci sono
altre fonti di valore da non trattare
strumentalmente e che richiedono
l'uscita dalla prospettiva
antropocentrica l'uscita cioè da quella
prospettiva in cui si dice che solo
l'uomo ei suoi nel rapporto con i suoi
simili definisce i valori per parlare di
questo per vedere come si sviluppa
questo discorso
dobbiamo partire disegno filosofia
dobbiamo partire dalla grande svolta
kantiana
perché lui a fine settecento mette le
basi per l'etica dei due secoli
successivi ancora qualcosa di valido
nella sua etica c'è
vi propongo tre brevi frasi la prima
delle quali è questa lui dice lui scrive
due cose riempiono l'animo di
ammirazione il cielo stellato sopra di
me la legge morale dentro di me così
come si vede il cielo stellato lui dice
io conosco dentro di me la legge morale
immediatamente in quanto persona
razionale in quanto persona che ha una
ragione io trovo una un criterio morali
è infatti la morale che canti propone
non è una morale che ci dice che cosa
fare per essere felici oppure per essere
perfetti per essere giusti ma è una
morale che ci dà un criterio per
orientarci nella vita orienta ceramica
chiedendoci
quali sono i valori etici che noi
portiamo avanti la seconda frase quella
più famosa agisce in modo che la massima
della tua azione individuale possa
diventare legge universale
questo cosa significa che se il
principio della mia azione può essere
esteso a tutti
e non è solo per me la mia azione sarà
positiva sarà buona se non potrà essere
esteso a tutti sarà negativa posso fare
qualche esempio esempi molto semplici
posso chiederti ad esempio se è giusto
non pagare tasse che considero troppo
alte proviamo estenderlo a tutti e siamo
in una contraddizione perché se nessuno
paga le tasse lo stato non esiste oppure
un'altra ancora più semplice è sbagliato
copiare i compiti a scuola
anche qui provate a fare il test
dell'universalità e se noi lo estendiamo
a tutti è chiaro che non c'è nessuno da
cui possiamo copiare quindi ci vuole
qualcuno che non copia quindi la mia
azione secondo principio kantiano è
sbagliata la terza frase è questa la
ritroveremo fino alla fine riformulata
come vedremo agisce in modo da
considerare umanità sempre come fine e
mai semplicemente come mezzo se io mi
considero un fine e di sicuro noi ci
consideriamo tutti un fine e non posso
per il principio dell'universalità non
pensare che anche gli altri siano dei
fini e quindi non potrò trattarli come
dei mezzi eccola l'etica kantiana che
come dicevo è una un'etica che ha messo
le basi
della cultura moderna e contemporanea
sembra con questo criterio
dell'universalità contenere tutto essere
inclusiva ma qualcuno osserva che
probabilmente lui incanti pensava solo
al rapporto nostro rapporto con i
contemporanei cioè con coloro che vivono
con noi e ma non teneva conto di una
cosa che fino a poco tempo apparsi fa si
dava per scontata e cioè
la continuazione dell'umanità futura
almeno nel modo in cui la conosciamo
oggi questa ci dice hans yonas che ha un
filosofo tedesco del novecento che
scrive nel
1979 il principio responsabilità
dice ecco questa oggi noi non possiamo
non porcelo come problema
di fronte alla minaccia della estinzione
di massa addirittura abbiamo afferma la
responsabilità nei confronti
dell'umanità futura
ecco
siamo alle liste di un'estensione di
massa ecco speriamo di no però abbiamo
visto che il nostro agire tecnico che
spesso agisce sul breve termine non
tiene conto delle conseguenze a lungo
termine che possono essere negative
comunque sono inaspettate sono negative
e spesso non sono controllabili e
possono mettere in discussioni o almeno
questa era la posizione di fatto di
jonas mettere in discussione la
sopravvivenza dell'umanità
lui riformula la seconda frase kantiana
che abbiamo visto agisce in modo che le
conseguenze della tua azione siano
compatibili con la continuazione di
un'autentica vita umana sulla terra
quindi le conseguenze l'attuazione
questo non è un discorso contro la
tecnica e le conseguenze della tecnica o
dell'azione umana è un discorso sulla
tecnica miope che non tiene conto delle
conseguenze a lungo termine
ma possono esserci altri altri
ampliamente di orizzonte l'ampliamento
dirlo orizzonte che abbiamo con
l'animalismo parte da un filosofo
inglese un filosofo
utilitarista inglese jeremy bentham che
tornando indietro ai tempi di cannes
scrive questa cosa un cavallo un cane
adulti sono senza paragoni animali più
razionali e più comunicativi di un
bambino di un giorno di una settimana e
persino di un mese non di più attenzione
ma anche ammesso che fosse altrimenti
che cosa importerebbe il problema non è
possono ragionare o possono parlare ma
possono soffrire
ecco ben dice che cosa abbiamo in comune
con gli animali non fosse lo stesso
grado di razionalità forse non lo stesso
uso del linguaggio articolato anche se
comunichiamo con gli animali e sappiamo
bene che ragionano a loro modo ma
sicuramente abbiamo in comune sullo
stesso piano la capacità di provare
piacere o dolore e questo è davvero
moralmente indifferente come fosse la
nostra civiltà ha pensato per secoli che
gli animali potessero essere degli
strumenti invece che
delle persone delle degli esseri con cui
entrare in contatto con cui di cui tener
conto
dal punto di vista della loro capacità
di soffrire di provare piacere e dolore
peter singer che ha un altro
guru diciamo degli animalisti e
contemporaneo ha scritto nel 1975 un
libro molto importante per gli
animalisti di oggi animal liberation che
parla della ma forse non possiamo
parlare degli interessi scusate dei
diritti degli animali perché per avere
dei diritti bisogna essere consapevoli
ma sicuramente possiamo dire che gli
animali hanno degli interessi e il primo
è quello a non soffrire
ma possiamo proseguire ancora
allargando sempre l'orizzonte
dell'etica a partire da kant
possiamo mettere al centro la vita il
biocentrismo
qui l'immagine è quella di rachel carson
che era una chimica americana
che ha scritto un bellissimo libro non è
un romanzo ma un libro di scienza
nel 1962 primavera silenziosa e in cui
si parla di tante cose ma al centro c.so
cioè la vita in tutte le sue varie forme
e forse però possiamo chiederci ma io
devo davvero
pormi dei problemi morali con gli
insetti i batteri le piante che non
hanno un cervello non hanno un sistema
nervoso è davvero una cosa che sono
piazza in soccorsi
ecco la risposta è questa che viene da
da lei ma anche da altri testi ogni
essere vivente ha un proprio bene cioè è
diretto a un fine anche non intenzionale
cioè non consapevole quello della sua
sopravvivenza e questo in quanto tale
non è subordinato a qualsiasi bene
altrui
cioè se un essere vivente ha una sua
ha un suo bene ha un suo fine che quello
della sua sopravvivenza e si muove verso
questo fine dobbiamo proprio dire che
noi possiamo farne a meno di tener conto
di questo e che quello può essere
subordinato al nostro guardate io qui
non voglio fare un discorso che sia
vegetariano vegano non sono vegetariana
né nulla
dico solo che con queste cose noi
dobbiamo entrare in dialogo noi dobbiamo
chiederci per esempio come arriviamo
agli animali tra l'altro non si vedono
non si sa bene come vivano ma gli
animali inferiori oppure le piante le
piante ecco qui vorrei citare uno
scienziato italiano finalmente uno scemo
che che molti di voi conoscono stefano
mancuso che ha studiato molto il regno
delle piante e la studiato da un punto
di vista scientifico non in modo
fantasioso e lui dice anche le piante
sono fornite di una forma di
intelligenza se per intelligenza
intendiamo la capacità di risolvere
problemi le piante hanno una
intelligenza diffusa su tutto il loro
corpo ma in particolare ce l'hanno lì né
gli apici radicali cioè nella punta
sottoterra delle radici dove dice
mancuso li devono prendere sempre delle
decisioni vado verso l'acqua vado verso
l'azoto verso i sali minerali come
faccio a superare un ostacolo non solo
le piante comunicano tra loro le piante
sanno distinguere amici e nemici cioè
sono un mondo complesso che spesso noi
sottovalutiamo
chi di voi che siamo in molti ad avere
chianti in casa lo sa ma
storicamente non ci poniamo non ci siamo
posti questo problema di un mondo ricco
ricco e complesso molto più ricca di
quanto non
siamo abituati a pensare
l'ultima l'ultimo ampliamento di
orizzonte è quello che ha chiamato
appunto un'etica della terra e che cos'è
cosa significa un'etica della terra la
terra ecco da intendere in due modi sia
come pianeta e sappiamo che dobbiamo
occuparci del nostro pianeta di sicuro
sia come suolo cioè tra la ci sono dei
libri anche sull'intelligenza del suolo
adesso siamo tutti intelligenti anche il
suolo ma è vero se lo leggete il libro
vi convincerà e cioè
anche il suolo ha una sua vitalità a una
sua complessità e un mondo senza il
quale noi non potremmo non potremmo
vivere insomma la nostra vita sarebbe
impossibile e allora possiamo dire che
l'intera biosfera e da considerare da un
punto di vista morale possiamo chiederci
una risposta viene da aldo leopold che
nel uno dei fondatori della wilderness
che nel 1949 suggeriva che dovremmo
pensare come una montagna
cioè che dovremmo tener conto mentre
facciamo delle scelte in cui
necessariamente
agiamo sulla natura la trasformiamo
dobbiamo tener conto anche del fatto che
la montagna alle rocce hanno una vita
una vita ma insomma una storia
sicuramente una storia che a scala non
umana con tempi molto diversi
è una voce che noi ascoltiamo a
pochissimo che non siamo abituati di cui
non siamo abituati a tener conto ecco
qui si dice questo pensare come una
montagna fosse una buona idea lovelock
che vedete qui in questa bella foto che
è un kimi era un chimico era un chimico
inglese morto pochi giorni fa al 103
anni
che scrivere ha scritto molti libri su
gaia gaia è il
[Musica]
nome della terra nella mitologia greca e
scrive che la terni insieme complesso di
relazioni tra viventi e non viventi un
superorganismo l'insieme organizzato di
organismi capace di autoregolazione e
cioè la terra è un insieme di un
rapporto tra ciò che vive e ciò che non
vive l'atmosfera le montagne il mare
l'oceano tutte queste cose collaborano
tra di loro e non possiamo pensare di
lasciar fuori nulla questo è l'idea che
viene fuori in questi ultimi anni questi
ultimi decenni e concludo brevemente con
la
questa domanda è possibile una sintonia
con non umano una domanda che si pone
questo filosofo americano di oggi tenuti
morton che dice allora accettato che noi
viviamo nell'era dell'antropocene cioè
quella era geologica in cui l'uomo è la
principale causa di cambiamento ecco
dobbiamo pensare che l'uomo non è
l'unica istanza da nascono da qui
nascono i valori come avevamo detto non
ci chiedevamo all'inizio è possibile
immaginare un etica della terra che
tenga conto dei tempi e dei valori
dell'intera biosfera
e ancora è possibile una sintonia con il
non umano cioè entrare in dialogo con
soprattutto con il mondo facciamo fatica
con il mondo in organico come il mondo
non vivente non sembra difficile entrare
in sintonia e possiamo possiamo
aggiungere anche questo che dice un
poeta romantico mi ha detto poeta
romantico quindi a fine settecento
novalis possiamo dare del tu alle rocce
con questa frase poetica molto
suggestiva e concludo l'ultima frase è
una riformulazione della terza frase
kantiana possiamo trattare l'intera
natura come fine e mai come mezzo grazie
[Applauso]